Music
Beyond the window, looking outside Time to wait so long in
this place Stories that never had a color now Begin to await
Your separate touches every corner Every day here's falling
to place again The world begins to move on For this feeling
we share Ties that will not change more than anything else
Start from there, I'm so it feels a bit strange Build a step
by step, never next to ever Heart below right now, how far
can we go?
To be a child, I'm walking up and When your eyes meet with
mine Lay on the moon, singing on the morning Take my hands
now, we're in this together Is this all my dreams?
Oh, I don't know But we can't find the answer someday Color
by color Painting the whole skyline Making it our own All
our colors merge as one you and I We make the wonders now
Ready for the new world
Signs of love, longing and even rage Endless spots hidden in
the silent mist Ready for it all Whatever you dream,
whatever you imagine Make them all come true, reach them in
this new world Press the button, dive into the story And now
we are flying higher, higher than ever Close your eyes for
me here, my guiding voice To the edge of the world, looking
up there Where your eyes meet the star Play on, play on, oh
destiny No, look at that Is this all our dreams?
Well, I don't know, but we can find the answer someday Like
one, my color, my color Painting all the sky, why make it
our own?
All our colors merge as one, you and I We make the wonders
now Ready for the new world